what is it
what's the role of consciousness in um
let's say even just the thing we've been
talking about which is the formation of
this interface
um
but any kind of ways you want to kind of
start sure tracking and talking about it
well let me say first what most of my
colleagues say
99
are again assuming that space time is
fundamental
particles in space-time matter is
fundamental
and most are reductionist
and so the standard approach to
consciousness is to figure out
what
complicated systems of matter
with the right functional properties
could possibly lead to the emergence of
consciousness that's the general idea
right
so
maybe you have to have neurons maybe
only if you have neurons but
that might not be enough they have to
certain kinds of complexity in their
their organization and their dynamics
certain kind of network abilities for
example
so there's
there are those who say for example that
um
consciousness arises from orchestrated
collapse of quantum states of
microtubules in neurons
so this is
hammer off and penrose have that's kind
of
so it's it's a you start with something
physical a
property of quantum states of neurons
of microtubules and neurons and you say
that somehow an orchestrated collapse of
those
is consciousness or conscious
experiences
or integrated information theory again
you start with something physical
and if it has the right kind of
functional properties it's something
they call fee with the right kind of
integrated information then you have
consciousness
or you can be a a pan psychist
philip gough for example where you you
might say well in addition to the the
particles in space and time
those particles are not just matter they
also could have see a unit of
consciousness
and so but once again you're taking
space and time and particles is
fundamental
and you're adding um a new property to
them see the consciousness and then you
have to talk about how when a proton and
neutron
where proton and electron get together
to form hydrogen then how those
consciousnesses
merge to or interact to create the
consciousness of of hydrogen and so
forth
um there's attention schema theory which
again this is how neural
network processes representing to the
network itself it's attentional
processes that could be consciousness
um there's global workspace theory
and neuronal global works experience
workspace theory so there's many many
theories of this type what's what's
common to all of them
is they assume that space time is
fundamental
they assume that physical processes and
space time is fundamental
pan psychism adds consciousness says an
additional thing is almost duelist in
that regard
and
my attitude is
our best science is telling us
that space time is not fundamental
so
why is that important here well for
centuries
deep thinkers
thought of
earth air fire and water as the
fundamental elements it was a
reductionist kind of idea
nothing was more elemental than those
and you could you could sort of build
everything up from those
when we got the periodic table of
elements
we realized that um
of course we want to study earth air
fire and water there's combustion
science for fire there's you know
there's sciences for for
all these other things water and so
forth so we're going to do science with
these things but but fundamental no no
if you're looking for something
fundamental those are the wrong building
blocks
earth has many many different kinds of
elements
that project into the one thing that we
call earth if you don't understand that
there's silicon that there's iron that
there's all these different kinds of
things that project into what we call
earth
you're you're you're hopelessly lost
you're not fundamental you're not going
to get there
and then
after the periodic table then we came up
with quarks leptons and gluons the the
particles of the standard you know the
standard model of physics
and and and so we actually now know that
if you really want to get fundamental
the periodic table isn't it it's good
for chemistry it's just wonderful for
chemistry but if you're trying to go
deep fundamental what is the fundamental
science that's not it you're going to
have to go to
quarks leptons and gluons and so forth
well now
we've discovered space-time itself is
doomed quarks leptons and gluons are
just irreducible representations of the
symmetries of space-time
so
the whole framework on which
consciousness research is being based
right now
is doomed
and for me
these are my friends and colleagues that
are doing this they're brilliant they're
absolutely they're they're brilliant i
my feeling is
i'm so sad
that they're stuck with this old
framework because if they they weren't
stuck like with earth air fire and water
you could actually make progress so it
doesn't matter how smart you are if you
start with earth air fire and water
you're not going to get anywhere right
can i actually just uh because the word
doomed is so interesting
let me give you some options multiple
choice quiz
is space time we could say is reality
the way we perceive it
doomed
um
wrong
or
fake
because doomed just means it could still
be
right
and we're now ready to go deeper
it would be that so it's not wrong it's
not a complete
deviation from a journey toward the
truth
right it's like earth air fire and water
is not wrong there is earth air fire and
water
that's a useful framework but it's not
fundamental right well there's also
wrong which is
they used to believe as i recently
learned that george washington was
the president of the first president in
the united states was bled to death
uh for something that could have been
easily treated
because it was believed that you can get
actually i need to look into this
further but i guess you get toxins out
or demons out i don't know what you're
getting out with the bleeding of a
person right
but so that ended up being
wrong but widely believed as a medical
tool
so
it's also possible that
our assumption of space-time is not just
doomed but it's wrong
well if we believe that it's fundamental
that's wrong
but if we believe it's a useful tool
that's right but he could see but
bleeding somebody to death was believed
to be a useful tool
it wasn't just not fundamental right it
was very
i'm sure there's cases in which bleeding
somebody would work but it would be a
very tiny tiny tiny percentage
of cases uh so it could be that it's
wrong like it's a side road that's
ultimately leading to a dead end
as opposed to a truck stop or something
that you can get off of
my feeling is is not the dead end kind
of thing i think that the what the
physicists are finding is that there are
these structures beyond space time but
they project back into space time and so
space time
when they when they say space time is
doomed they're explicit they're saying
it's doomed in the sense that we thought
it was fundamental it's not fundamental
it's a useful absolutely useful and
brilliant data structure but there are
deeper data structures like cosmological
polytube
and and and space time is not
fundamental what is doomed
in the sense that is wrong
is
reductionism
which is saying space-time is
fundamental
right right the idea that that somehow
being smaller in space and time or
space-time is a fundamental nature of
reality that's is a that's that's just
wrong it turned out to be a useful
heuristic for for thermodynamics and so
forth and in several other places it
reductionism has been very useful but
that's in some sense
an artifact of how we use our interface
um yes you're saying size doesn't matter
okay this is very important for me
ultimately ultimately right it's useful
for for theories like thermodynamics and
also for understanding brain networks in
terms of individual neurons and neurons
in terms of
chemical
systems inside cells that's all very
very useful
but but the idea that we're getting to
the more fundamental nature of reality
no you when you get all the way down in
that direction you get down to the
quarks and gluons what you realize is
what you've gotten down to is not
fundamental reality just the irreducible
representations of a data structure
that's all you've gotten down to so
you're always stuck
inside the data structure
so you seem to be getting closer and
closer i went from neural networks to
neurons to neurons to chemistry
chemistry to particles particles to
clerks and gluons
i'm getting closer and closer to the
real no i'm getting closer and closer to
the actual structure of the data
structure of space and time the
irreducible representations that's what
you're getting closer to not to a deeper
understanding of what's beyond space
time we'll also refer
we'll return again to this question of
dynamics
because you keep
saying that space time is doomed but
mostly focusing on the space part of
that it's very interesting to see why
why time gets the bad
cred too because how do you have
dynamics without time is the thing i'd
love to talk to you a little bit about
but let us return
um
your brilliant
whirlwind overview of the different
theories of consciousness that are out
there
what is consciousness if outside of
space-time
if we think that we want to have a model
of consciousness we as scientists then
have to
say what do we want to write down what
what kind of mathematical model are we
going to write down right and if you
think about it there's lots of things
that you might want to write down about
consciousness a lot was fairly
complicated subject
um
so most of my colleagues are saying
let's start with matter or neurons and
and um
say what properties of matter could
create consciousness but i'm saying that
that whole thing is out space time is
doomed that whole thing is out
we need to look at consciousness qua
consciousness
in other words not as something that
arises in space and time but perhaps
it's something that creates space and
time as a data structure
so what do we want and here again
there's no hard and fast rule but what
you as a scientist have to do is to pick
what you think are the minimal
assumptions
that are going to allow you to boot up a
comprehensive theory
that is the trick
so what do i want so what what i chose
to do was to have three things
i said that there are conscious
experiences
feeling of headache the smell of garlic
um
experiencing the color red there are
those are conscious so that's a
primitive theory and the reason i want
few primitives why because those are the
miracles of the theory right the
primitives the assumptions of your
theory are the things you're not going
to explain those are the things you
assume and those experiences you
particularly mean
there is a subjectiveness to them that's
what's the thing when people refer to
the heart problem of consciousness
is it feels like something
to look at the color red okay exactly
right it feels like something to have a
headache or to feel
upset to your stomach it feels like
something
and so though so i'm going to grant that
in this theory
there are experiences and they're
fundamental in some sense so conscious
experience so they're not derived from
physics they're not
functional properties of particles they
are sewed generous they're they exist
just like we assume space-time exists
i'm now saying space-time is just a data
structure it doesn't exist independent
of
conscious experiences sorry to interrupt
once again but should we be focusing in
your thinking on humans alone
or is there something
[Music]
about
in relation to other kinds of organisms
that have a sufficiently high level of
complexity or even uh
or is there some kind of
uh
generalization of the pan cyclist idea
that all
consciousness permeates all matter
outside of the usual definition of what
matter is inside space-time so
it's beyond human consciousness human
consciousness from my point of view
would be
one of a countless variety of
consciousnesses
and even within human consciousness
there's a there's countless variety of
consciousness within us right
you have your left and right hemisphere
and apparently if you split the corpus
callosum the the personality of the left
hemisphere and the religious beliefs of
the left hemisphere can be very
different from the right hemisphere and
their conscious experiences
can be
disjoint one could have one conscious
experience they can play 20 questions
the left hemisphere can have an idea in
this mind and the right hemisphere has
to guess and it might not get it so so
even within you there is more than just
one consciousness it's
lots of consciousnesses so i the the
general theory of consciousness that i'm
after is not just human consciousness
it's going to be just consciousness and
i presume human consciousness is a tiny
drop in the bucket of the infinite
variety of consciousnesses that said i
should clarify that the black hole of
consciousness is uh
the the the home cat i'm pretty sure
cats lack
uh is the embodiment of evil and lack
all capacity for consciousness or
compassion so i just want to leave that
on the table but that's the theory i'm
working i don't have any good evidence
it's just a shout out
uh sorry to distract so that's the first
assumption first assumption that's right
the the second assumption is that these
experiences have consequences
so
i'm going to say that conscious
experiences can trigger other conscious
experiences somehow
so
so really in some sense there there's
two basic assumptions there's some kind
of causality is there's a chain of
causality does this relate to dynamics
i'll say there's a probabilistic
relationship okay
um and then
so i'm trying to be
as non-specific to begin with and see
where it it leaves me so what i can
write down are probability spaces
so probability space which contains the
conscious experiences that this
consciousness can have so i i'll
i call this a conscious agent
this technical thing now i
annika harris and i've talked about this
and and she rightly
cautions me that people will think that
i'm bringing in a notion of a cell for
agency and so forth when i say conscious
agent so i just want to say that i use
the term conscious agent merely as a
technical term
there is no notion of self in my
fundamental definition of a conscious
station there are only experiences
and probabilistic relationships that of
how they trigger other experiences so
the agent is the generator of the
conscious experience the agent
is a mathematical structure that
includes a probability measure
a probability space
of possible conscious experiences and
what in a markovian kernel
which describes how
if this agent has certain conscious
experiences how that will affect the
experiences of other conscious agents
okay including itself but you don't
think of that as a self
no there there is no notion of of a self
here
there's no notion of of really of an
agent
but is there a locality
is there an organization
so this is this is um these are
conscious
units conscious entities but they're
distinct
in some way because they have to
interact
well so here's the interesting thing
when we write down the mathematics
um when you have two of these conscious
agents interacting they s the the pair
satisfy the definition of a conscious
agent so they are a single conscious
agent
so there is one conscious agent yeah but
it it has a nice analytic decomposition
into as many conscious agents that's a
nice interface
it's a very useful uh scientific
interface yeah it's it's a scale free or
if you like a fractal-like
approach to it in which we can use the
same unit of analysis at all scales in
in studying consciousness but if i want
to talk about
so there's no notion of learning
memory
problem solving intelligence self
agency
so none of that is fundamental
so and the reason i did that was
because
i want to assume as little as possible
everything i assume is a miracle in the
theory it's not something you explain
it's something you assume so i have to
build networks of conscious agents
if i want to have a notion of a self i
have to build a self
i have to build learning memory problem
solving intelligence and planning all
these different things i have to build
networks of conscious agents to do that
it's a trivial theorem that networks of
conscious agents are computationally
universal that's trivial so anything
that we can do with neural networks or
you know
automata you can do with networks of
conscious agents that's trivial
but
but you can also do more
the
events in the probability space need not
be computable so
the markovian dynamics is not restricted
to computable
functions
because the very events themselves need
not be computable
so so this can capture any computable
theory
anything we can do with neural networks
we can do with conscious agent networks
but but it leaves open the door for the
possibility of of non-computable um
interactions between conscious agents so
we have to to if we want a theory of of
memory
we have to build it
and there's lots of different ways you
could build we've actually got a paper
chris fields took the lead on this and
he
we have a paper called conscious agent
networks where where chris takes the
lead and shows how to use these networks
of conscious agents to build memory and
to build
primitive kinds of of of learning
but
can you uh provide some intuition of
what conscious networks network of
conscious networks of conscious agents
helps you
first of all what that looks like
uh
and i don't just mean mathematically of
course maybe that might help build up
intuition but how that helps us
potentially solve the heart problem of
consciousness
right
or is that
baked in that that exists
is
can you solve the hard problem of
consciousness why it tastes delicious
when you eat a delicious ice cream
uh with uh networks of conscious agents
or is that taken as an assumption so the
the standard way the heart problem
is thought of is
we're
assuming space and time in particles or
neurons for example
these are just physical things that that
have no consciousness and we have to
explain how the conscious experience of
the taste of chocolate could emerge from
those so that's the typical hard problem
of consciousness is that problem right
how do you boot up the taste of
chocolate the experience with a taste of
chocolate from neurons say or the right
kind of artificial intelligence
circuitry
how do you boot that up that's that's
typically what the hard problem of
consciousness means to to researchers
notice that i'm changing the problem
i'm not trying to boot up conscious
experiences from the dynamics of neurons
or silicon or something like that i'm
saying that that's the wrong problem
my heart problem would go in the other
direction if i start with conscious
experiences
how do i build up space and time how do
i build up what i call the physical
world how do i build up what we call
brains
because i'm saying
consciousness is not something that
brains do
brains are something that consciousness
makes up
it's one among the experience it's an
experience an ephemeral experience in
consciousness i look inside so to be
very very clear right now i have no
neurons
if you looked
you would see neurons
that's a data structure that you would
create on the fly and it's a very useful
one as soon as you look away you garbage
collect that data structure just like
that necker cube that i was talking
about on the piece of paper when you
look you see a 3d cube
you create it on the fly as soon as you
look away
that's gone when you say you you mean a
human being scientist
right now that's right
more generally it'll be conscious agents
because as you pointed out in my asking
for a theory of questions only about
humans no it's it's
consciousness which human consciousness
is just a tiny
sliver
so but you are saying that there is
that's the useful data structure how
many other data structures are there
that's why i said you human if there's
another earth
if there's another alien civilization
and doing these kinds of investigations
would they come up with similar data
structures
probably not what is the space of data
structures i guess is what i'm asking um
my my guess is that
if consciousness is fundamental
consciousness is all there is
then
the only thing
that mathematical structure can be about
is possibilities of consciousness
and
that suggests to me that there could be
an infinite variety of consciousnesses
and
a
eventually small fraction of them use
space-time
data structures and the kinds of
structures that we use
there's an infinite variety of data
structures now this is very similar to
something that max tegmark has said but
i want to distinguish it he has his
level four
uh multiverse idea he thinks that
mathematics is fundamental
and and so that's the fundamental
reality and since there's an infinite
variety of
endless variety of mathematical
structures there's an infinite variety
of multiverses in his view
i'm saying something
similar in spirit but importantly
different
there's an infinite variety of
mathematical structures absolutely
but mathematics isn't the fundamental
reality in this in this framework
consciousness is
and mathematics is to consciousness
like bones are to an organism
you need the bones so mathematics is
is not divorced from consciousness but
it's not
the entirety of consciousness by any
means
and so there's an infinite variety of of
conscious consciousnesses and and and
signaling games that consciousnesses
could interact
via
and therefore worlds your common worlds
data structures
that they can use to to communicate
so space and time is just one of an
infinite variety and so i i think that
what will what we'll find is that as we
go outside of our little space-time
bubble
we will encounter
utterly alien forms of conscious
experience that we may not be able to
really
comprehend in the in the following sense
if i if i ask you to imagine a color
that you've never seen before
does anything happen
right nothing happens
nothing happens and
that's just one color i'm asking for
just a color we actually know by the way
that there apparently there are women
um called tetraphams
who have four color receptors
not just three
and kimberly jamison and others who've
studied these women have good evidence
that they apparently have a new
dimension of color experience
that the rest of us don't have so so
these women are apparently living in a
world of color that you and i can't even
concretely imagine no man can imagine
them yeah and and yet they're real color
experiences and so in that sense i'm
saying now take that little baby step oh
there are women who have color
experiences that i could never have well
that's shocking
now take that
infinite
there are consciousnesses
where every aspect of their
their experiences or is like that new
color it's something utterly alien
to you you you'd have nothing like that
and yet these are all possible varieties
of conscious experience when you say
there's a lot of consciousnesses it's a
singular consciousness
basically the set of possible
experiences you can have in that
subjective way
as opposed to the me the underlying
mechanism
because you say that you know having uh
extra color receptor
uh extra you know ability to have new
experiences that's somehow a different
consciousness is there a way to see that
as all the same consciousness the
subjectivity itself
right because when we have
two of these conscious agents
interacting in the mathematics they
actually satisfy the definition of a
conscious agent so in fact they are a
single conscious agent
so so in fact
one way to think about what i'm saying
i'm postulating with my colleagues
jayton and chris and others robert
brentner and so forth um
there is one big conscious agent
infinitely complicated
but fortunately
we can for analytic purposes break it
down all the way to in some sense the
simplest consciousness which has one
conscious experience one
i like this this one agent can
experience red 35 that's it that's what
that's what it experiences you can get
all the way down to that
so you think it's possible
that consciousness
whatever that is
is uh
much more is fundamental or at least
much more in the direction of the
fundamental
than his space time as we perceive it
that's the proposal
and therefore what i have to do in terms
of the heart problem of consciousness
is to show
how dynamical systems of conscious
agents could lead to what we call space
and time and neurons and brain activity
in other words we have to show
how you get space-time and
physical objects
in entirely from a theory of conscious
agents outside of space time with with
the dynamics outside of space time
so that's that's and i can tell you how
we plan to to do that but but that's
that's the idea
okay the magic of it the chocolate is
delicious
so so there's a mathematical kind of
thing that we could say here how it can
emerge within the system of networks of
conscience agents but
um
is there going to be at the end of of
the proof why chocolate is so delicious
or or no i guess i'm i'm going to ask
different kinds of dumb questions to try
to sneak up oh well that's the right
question and when i say that i took
conscious experiences as fundamental
what that means is
in the current version of my theory i'm
not explaining conscious experiences
where they came from
that's the miracle that's one of the
miracles so i have two miracles in my
theory there are conscious experiences
like the taste of chocolate
and
that the
there's a probabilistic relationship
when certain conscious experiences occur
others are more likely to occur
those are the two miracles that
are possible to
get beyond
that
and somehow start to chip away at the
miracle-ness of that miracle
that chocolate is still delicious i hope
so i've got my hands full with what i'm
doing right now but but the uh i can
just say at top level how i would think
about that that would get at this
consciousness without form
this this is going to be really this is
really tough because it's
consciousness without form versus the
various forms that consciousness
takes for the experiences that it has
right right
so there's
so when i write down
a probability space
for these conscious experience i say
here's a probability space for the
possible conscious experiences right
it's just like when i write down a
probability space for an experiment like
i'm gonna flip a coin twice right and i
want to look at the probabilities of
various outcomes so i have to write down
the probability space there could be
heads heads heads tails tails heads
tails tails
so you before as
any class and probability you're told
write down your probability space if you
don't write down your probability space
you can't get started
so here's my probability space for
consciousness
how do i want to interpret that
structure the structure is just sitting
there there's going to be a dynamics
that happens on it right
experiences appear and they disappear
just like heads appears and disappears
so
so
one way to think about that
fundamental probability space is that
corresponds to consciousness without any
content the infinite consciousness
that transcends
any particular content
well do you think of that as a mechanism
as a thing
like the the rules that govern the
dynamics of the thing outside of space
time isn't that if you think
consciousness is fundamental isn't it
essentially getting like
it is solving the hard problem
which is like
from uh
where does this thing pop up which is
the mechanism of the thing popping up
whatever the consciousness is the
different kinds it was so on that
mechanism
and also the the question i want to ask
is uh how
how tricky do you think it is
to solve that problem
you've solved a lot of difficult
problems throughout the history of
humanity
um there's probably
uh
more problems to solve
left than we've solved by like
an infinity
uh but along that long journey
of intelligent species
how when will we solve this
consciousness one which is one way to
measure the difficulty of the problem
so i'll give two answers there's one
problem i think we can solve
but we haven't solved yet and that is
the reverse of what
my colleagues call the heart problem
the problem of how do you start with
conscious experiences in the way that
i've just described them in the dynamics
and build up space and time and brains
that i think is a tough technical
problem but some principle solvable so i
think we can solve that
so we would solve the hard problem not
by showing how brains create
consciousness but how networks of
conscious agents create what we call the
the symbols that we call brains
so that that i think
but that does that allow you to so
that's interesting that's an interesting
idea consciousness creates the brain not
the brain creates consciousness but does
that allow you to build the thing
my guess is that it will
enable unbelievable technologies
once
and i'll tell you why i think it plugs
into the work that the physicists are
doing so this theory of consciousness
will be even deeper than the structures
that the physicists are finding like the
amplitude
but the other but the other answer to
your question is less positive
i as i said earlier i think that there
is no such thing as a theory of
everything
so that
i think that my
the theory that my team is working on
this conscious station theory is just a
1.0 theory theory
we're using
probability spaces and markovian curls i
can easily see people now saying well we
can do better if we go to category
theory
and we can
get a deeper perhaps more interesting
and then someone will say well now i'll
go to topoi theory and then they'll be
so i imagine that there'll be you know
conscious agents 5
10
3 trillion 0.0
but i think it will never end i think
ultimately
this question that we sort of put our
fingers on of
how
does the formless
give birth to form
to the taste the wonderful taste of
chocolate
i think that we will always go deeper
and deeper but we will never solve that
that that in some sense that will be a
primitive i hope i'm wrong
maybe i'm maybe it's just the the limits
of my current imagination
um so i'll just say my imagination right
now
doesn't
appear that deep
hopefully so i don't by the way i'm
saying this i don't want to discourage
some brilliant 20 year old
who then later on proves me dead wrong i
i hope to be proven dead right just like
you said a century from now everything
we're saying now everything you're
saying all your theories will be
laughing stock they will respect
the uh
the the the puzzle solving abilities and
how how much we were able to do with so
little but uh outside of that
it will all be just uh
the silliness will be entertainment for
a teenager
you